Aaron count me down from 1,000 let me
know when we're good
well mm-hmm I'm waiting guys welcome to
punch song sports hey everyone
and now who knows what's gonna happen
today I know Ari's on his way
I know Ari Shaffir is in Los Angeles
because I've been smoking pot with him
for the last two days I know that we did
a patreon the other night I know fight
nanny could be here fight mommy could be
here Danish could be here Bert Kreischer
and Steve Rannazzisi we're supposed to
be here
I know Rena ZZ will not be here because
he texted me
Ari's on his way I know we're having a
barbecue at Rena zzs house and here's
what I texted him just so you know he's
very worried about a lot of things and
he goes hey everybody here's the address
for the he's having a barbecue for
because so Ari can see the baby the
punch room the baby the punch-drunk
helped facilitate the baby the
punch-drunk build barbecue at 3 p.m.
guns not permitted and then there's a
little star and it says that's for Ryan
O'Neal only and then it's his address
and I said can my friend bring a gun if
it's not O'Neal also can I bring a
friend and this metal band for drummers
they're prolific as hell anywho see you
when you get here we let ourselves in we
need to rehearse
god no reply and I think I'm uninvited
this thing so are he's on his way
they were shooting and all things comedy
thing at a crisis house they were doing
a cooking thing in crisis hi so no no
this is because I was talking to Bill
come and he goes we had to text um
crisis wife and set and we said hey we
need to get there by like 6:00 a.m. to
set everything up and just letting you
know you know is that ok and she goes
it's okay I'll make room for you guys
I'll clean out the mancave
also don't get here until 7:00 and don't
even think of having me involved in
anything until 8:30 so that's that's
that's what 6:00 a.m. means in the
Chrysler house so I don't know who's
gonna show up I don't already showing up
and you know momentarily or
what-have-you but I have no idea if
nanny baby mommy
well nanny is yeah she's always cry sure
cry sure though maybe not who knows but
I know our he's on his way
we did a patreon last name yeah and Ari
was literally nodding off he hosted so
he hosted the the he flew up for them
for the big mitts he thing which was
amazing that thing was incredible they
had this big kind of a it wasn't so much
of that wasn't like a funeral vibe it
was more of like a celebration of of the
Comedy Store and her vision of the
Comedy Store and pretty much her life in
general and so many I mean Jim Carrey
was there we Roseanne Barr was there I
mean it was stars somewhat star-studded
thing at least in the realm of comedy
and it was more specifically the comedy
stores version of comedy so it wasn't
every famous comedian in the world it
was every comedian that had ever been a
door guy there or worked there you know
drew Carey of all these different people
were there and it was super fun and so I
saw Ari alright keep it that's why he
came out or he came back for that and so
then we did a patreon last night and
this dude is literally nodding off he's
Aaron he was literally like he was like
catch himself like you fall asleep in
like English class when you're like 13
it was like he was literally being like
well you know give him credit though he
was he managed to stay in the
conversation and he hosted a maybe 60
person comedy show for three hours like
60 people probably yeah they went so
like a
every three minutes yeah yeah so yeah
and he was like in Australia [ __ ] I
don't know what two three years how long
was in two years
weeks he's there for like three weeks or
something then flew back to New York
then flew here and then host and then
went to that mitzi thing and then hosted
the next night and then had to get up
today he was counting during our patreon
okay if I go to sleep now I got you so
that's the work okay that'll be six
hours of sleep okay I can't get behind
that and I'm like you know I fell asleep
on Saturday I woke up Tuesday I think I
mean I have different different did you
watch any of the UFC I watched a little
of a watch boxing I need to watch this I
did watch boxing again I was alone with
Chico and Linares is here is lomachenko
underrated knows he's not a household
name he's not on a ready though well
boxing boxing fans boxing fans he's a
household name but he's not somebody you
know my sister knows he's not some you
know my sister would know triple G my
sister would know you know Canelo out
but lemon chenko is not a household name
like your average fan as he's underrated
yeah but the press thinks he's the next
coming of Jesus so no he's not
underrated by them but yeah like he's
also not that ladies and gentleman who's
at the doorbell was that do we have a
new doorbell Erin what was that yeah
that's our new doorbell he's and
gentlemen please welcome to the show
yeah that's nice too Rogers I should go
into that but I bet it that documentary
looks cool yeah yeah it does I hope it
ends up him like just raping kids I hope
it ends with him just Bill Cosby and
[ __ ] Sam Harry of course he does mo
he's a spy bro mr. Rogers that's what he
thinks about he was a lizard person like
what what's a lizard person he'll he'll
throw words out there that I don't even
know that's a lizard person well you
know what that is it's this guy called
David Icke he thinks that there are in
the
high positions in government these
people who can cloak their lizards they
they're like bipedal lizards and they
can cloak their skin they can change
their skin and will they go back and
find these old shitty videos that look
like grainy and they say oh you can see
the hologram like it's uh it's kind of
showing right here you know what I
created I stand corrected that makes
total sense and it's just bad video I'm
all hundred percent behind that now that
I think of it you don't see anything
more now that we have 4k
and if it was true he would expect to
see more of it people have gotten uglier
yeah that's what happens yeah anyway he
thinks that childish gambino is also a
CA a psychological operation why would
that be I'm not really sure what the
point of that psych op would be well the
point is there's a video that a lot of
people are watching yeah so it must you
know so it's got to be something else
other than people want to all watch this
video by the way I'd like to say a big
thank you to everybody who's kept this
Michael Jordan LeBron thing going on
Twitter with Sam oh man it's been it's
been laborious to say the least this
look I mean last night we're on the on
the patreon are you and I came up with
the thing of like and I guess I'm
breaking the rule right now but we have
a new rule on the show we can't say that
the l word anymore mmm LeBron James we
can't even do it we're not even gonna
say his name on this show otherwise
show's ruined mentioning that young
gentleman's name who I shall not which I
gotta turn out that that first game
against the Celtics did go to prove
Sam's point a little bit I'm at least
gloating on Twitter but maybe perhaps he
was but you know what else you know what
else happened remember when they lost a
first playoff game by 31 yeah and then
they won eight straight games in a row
yeah so we'll see so we'll see that is a
team that is well coached of the Celtics
or well coached can you imagine I love
that guy they had their two star I mean
the
two of their best players are out
Hayward and [ __ ] Kyrie Irving think
about that if they had those guys good
would they be I mean they're there and
they're also like like remember in the
Marvel Universe win I mean I mean Stark
Iron Man built the Hulk Buster uh-huh
it's like a looks like a giant Hulk
version of Iron Man yeah and that's just
to solely fight the Hulk because nobody
could beat the Hulk that's what the
Celtics are it's like the LeBron buster
oh I see like they built a team to get
to beat LeBron and you know to get out
of the East basically they didn't build
a team to beat the Warriors it was like
the NFC South with Michael Vick
like he's the reason we drafted to the
Panthers drafted Thomas Davis is because
I needed some I despite yeah you know
buddy everybody which starts buying the
quarterback back then everybody would
spikes what about yeah you had it and
you had to drive somebody if you played
them twice a year you had to drive
somebody could do it yeah I think
they're like I don't want to say
supports greatness but because that's
gonna be grandiose but people when when
you start playing video games when you
have to change the way you play defense
in a video game because of somebody's
offense you know I mean that's how
that's I mean you've seen that in the
NFC you've seen that in the NFL you've
seen that in the NBA wherever like when
everyone's like I want to be the Falcons
all of a sudden like yeah you know much
that pissed me off
well was just Falcons because I play I
plus ba I mean I'm like from Tecmo ball
mmm - all the way through Madden forever
even including like the shitty games
like NFL Blitz there was all these dumb
one blitz was like basically like their
attempt at um NBA Jam exactly that's
right anybody's yeah it was like but it
wasn't as fun as NBA Jam but I would
always be the Falcons and I never had
any guff growing up in Chicago and then
going to school in the middle of Indiana
and like I never and I when I first went
nobody wanted to be the Falcons so it
was perfect anytime I would play video
games with someone Chris Chandler
nobody ever absent Lee Christian it
nobody ever wanted
be them and then Michael Vick came along
and then Vick was on the cover and
everybody was just like I'm just gonna
get 287 yards rushing with Michael Vick
and I'm never gonna have to learn the
minutiae of football and out route and
whatever you had to do in Madden I was
actually using Michael Vick like we
would use Michael Vick you know I was
such a football game oh I see I would
actually run our real plays and I would
really [ __ ] make moves you know if we
cut somebody BAM you're off the [ __ ]
team I'm a [ __ ] man naked bootleg
yeah PlayStation 2 like we cut you
[ __ ] you then guess what
see you [ __ ] you know whatever
[ __ ] whoever we dropped yeah yeah my
roster was saved onto them because but
remember their memory cards oh of course
yeah so my memory card row is like be
the most updated thing so if I went to
your house and we're gonna play Madden
I'm like I'll bring my memory card no
I'm bringing my [ __ ] and we're gonna
play on my memory card not your dumb
[ __ ] yeah okay I'm not gonna plan your
[ __ ] stupid things I got I'm sorry
whoever you have otro Cinco on the
[ __ ] dolphins
that's not real that's what you want to
happen Miami fan this microphone smells
so bad like that
oh god that's the one I [ __ ] farted in
two with my dick no you never smell
microphone but this even from this
distance is really bad why what do you
think it is I'm not gonna know that's
like when a basement like a baby was
like no no never smell a baby's finger
somebody like ate [ __ ] and then talked
into it yeah well welcome to punch chunk
[ __ ] was he walking from the studio what
the [ __ ] who Ari
oh I forgot Ari's alive um who knows
you're a that's when I it's like I mean
it's just a few blocks how many blocks
would you say that is Aaron no he's not
there I don't think they're there they
were shooting at crisis house oh yeah
that's what I've seen earlier that's why
his wife was like okay cool yeah get
here at 6:00 a.m. that sounds great get
here at 7:00 a.m. and don't even think
about waking me up till 8:30
that was her response too I got coming
at 6:00 okay that sounds great get Hertz
have
and then don't even wake me up today
we're just going to pick him up what uh
no that were they doing that cooking
thing I think so do you know Aaron yeah
that's what they're doing cooking dinner
Aaron do you still not have a mic all
right we don't really apparently seem to
need that I that's the other funny thing
I go Aaron first of all I'd like to show
my permanent file not only am I on time
I'm early like I'm always early I'll
take some also also when you write
together absolutely right absolutely
right but um but I'm talking five
studios oh I see seven years always
always first and on time or whatever see
the latest
ooh nanny or Sam is the latest Oh Sam
always employs an 'm and he walks in on
his own with like a at least one dog um
and sometimes I guess that nobody know
about yeah yeah I don't know the so and
then I say to Aaron and by the way we
need five mics because we have so many
people that are gonna show up and be on
time and [ __ ] do this podcast and
they're excited to be here and I thank
them for that
and Aaron goes you know what that sucks
I have to give up my own mic but I'll do
it for the integrity of this goddamn
show and now [ __ ] five [ __ ] empty
mics in front of me it's only I'm
looking at and eventually it's like you
know I'm outside talking to my goddamn
mother love him I'm outside talking to
my goddamn mother how's she
she's good she's dying and so I [ __ ]
cold
no she doing she was bitching at me
about doing uh was he called mescaline
no no no no no no ether well it's it's
it's elderly mess suicides drum drum
aerobics she's doing drummer oh oh she's
doing it bitching bitching at me about
it
guys are trying to [ __ ] kill me Jase
she just calls me Jase they're trying to
[ __ ] kill me with this drum aerobics
well who's got the drum it's like you're
not medicine balls but you know those
bouncy balls people sit on a [ __ ] it's
the bit like you know it's like I don't
say old but it's like older people you
know drumming to the Beatles or whatever
[ __ ] on the ball
yeah just like it's like I look like
cheap car I call it cheap car do okay
yeah so it's like aerobics but it's like
set to music and like you're doing drums
and others oh well well well listen uh
Steve sit down
Brenna's Easy's here everybody oh so is
Ari Shaffir we were just talking about
um this little get-together at your
place yeah my buddies are already there
yeah it's funny you say that no my
buddies my rings my ring alarm systems
been going off for the last half hour
and I was wondering why it's not long
day ya know they're setting up all right
just a couple of my buddies are in a
band they're in a 10-person that band
mostly metal is what you described to me
on the text message yeah they're a death
metal band for drummers and for drummers
seems excessive for well I mean I but
apparently like your neighbors have a
thing right now like they came over and
they're no they're pissed about yeah
they're already pissed yeah wouldn't why
do they don't like death metal or is a
separate reason no the the pyrotechnics
is their what their last pots going off
into their backyards this I guess with
their tree caught on fire yeah those are
oak trees in there oh they're like a
couple hundred years old I apparently oh
yeah they're all tagged individually
with the person's you know they're gone
that's not that's a no-go you have a lot
more a little a lot more natural light
in your kitchen hey guys welcome to show
we've already been going we're almost
done so guys that's how did it go today
it was pretty good I told him to get me
out of there earlier but yeah tell
everybody what you guys are doing you
were doing you were shooting a crisis
house right yeah
yeah southern externa with Bert
Kreischer uh-huh the new all things
comedy television show and it was a
blast yeah we did in his backyard and
compartment what did you guys make today
I'll get so disappointed at me I'll tell
you that
yeah only it food disappointing you want
well so he makes what the hot the cheese
dogs were good fun jalapeno and cheddar
links we did that first ground did you
eat it or do put it in your ass eat it
through someone's pool yep or it was
like I'm gonna pay this bet off right
now I'm just he said shoving all right
we were alfresco we were outside sitting
in his backyard so then the re would
take the food and throw it into his pool
and Burt would get all pissed off oh so
much starts a day off in the pool naked
grinds the beef himself puts like the
perfect amount of cheese on it cooked it
perfectly make bacon in a pan on the
grill yep
drape those over it everyone you know
[ __ ] good and then it was like it was
like camera and I I immediately want to
swap it out of hours of preparing this I
don't know what it was yeah
the continent cut yeah that's two hours
of prep work like and then smoke and
join strait of beers having fun laughing
enough nothing leads to this no
animosity nothing at all
showing the camera the final reveal it's
finger I mean but here's a problem
something stopped me yeah I need this
and I was like wait are we sure I was
like no maybe not and then it was like
coming over I didn't do it
any didn't I was like what the [ __ ] well
I don't know what happened are you in
love I was no I knew to do it I flashed
in my head it's like maybe sing like a
TV show and maybe it's in him in like
Callen we're all dirty so I thought
maybe they had done something like that
yeah okay yeah but that but those guys I
mean looking back I still should have
done it yeah instinct was real I don't
know
I yeah it kind of makes me feel weird I
thought it was perfect it was like oh
yeah oh do I just I'm going to take a
piss on two and a half hours of all his
dedication to a craft and then it's like
see this isn't any like normal cooking
show they have like three more sitting
in the back no Bert made three yeah
there's a like you're picking it up off
the ground and putting it back on the
grill like okay well this delicious
cooking on that grass on it'll cook it
off cook it off fire cures all it was
fun though we did take our shirts off
for the majority of it you look like you
got Sun you look so tired still hahaha
no you just look high
I slept but it was nice though yeah okay
[ __ ] I want a backyard man okay you
have one have fun but not like that
where it's like wide open
oh he's got a he's got a good yard you
know you just tell me that you know he
had a I don't know if he still does but
the last time was aired this trampoline
for the kids and he goes dude I just
came out cuz he's in the valley girls
come out and there's just a [ __ ]
Falcon just in the middle of the
trampoline just looking at all these
chickens yeah we got it I got a B yeah
[ __ ] Allen that's why he forgot he
got one of those fake owls
to scare off all the other yeah but he
goes does it just [ __ ] you know three
foot Falcon just sittin in the middle of
his trampoline it's like staring at all
these chickens of exotic birds all over
the place for the kids baseball practice
and [ __ ] people bring their pet um what
are the ones you keep in your house oh
Bulger's no different parakeets and they
bring them to the park and they let him
out and they fly around and we'll come
back to the people but they're
distracting is [ __ ] like dragons flying
all over the oh yeah seem safe I mean
yeah the birds I don't trust I don't
trust him towards children poop around
you're saying yeah I mean hey witch Hey
we're doing a test on this we do this on
a patreon which Muppet do you think
Johnny would wear most sounds like I'm
here
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna indulge this
gonzo beaker that's good
uncool how fun was MIT seasoning the
other day we were talking about all but
for you I've been pretty nice man yeah I
had a good time I did see the one
picture you see I think Troy took one of
he was a muscleman on the roof yeah
during that whole everybody in the
bottom bottom yen in the parking lot and
you could sit there and play Where's
Waldo with a couple really like you know
oh there's Saget there's [ __ ] David
[ __ ] popped up over the whole crowd
ohs David Taylor the blue shirt he had
the blue shirt in had on so everything
was yeah he's a full head above everyone
else guys
with his holsters dice Jimmy Walker that
were you there with Holtzman at the end
yeah also made us go up to Tyson ask for
comedy advice you would know yeah oh no
I wasn't it was like what he was talking
about binder and uh and uh Mike finder
and Jimmy Walker somebody like that yeah
and there's somebody Terry basil and
then uh we're like he's like what Harry
bass
Holtzman is just like smiling staring is
like we're here for pretty good some
comedy but we'd like to hear it economy
of mice you might have for us and he was
like what yeah let's get some comedy
advice from you and he was like walk
away kick rocks you dumb [ __ ] Beta Beta
Beta Heroes
yep all zeroes rifling through my hair
figures that's what you're doing Oh what
happened over the phone it's waterproof
its water no I think it's like runs on
water it does water it yeah hundred
percent tested on two percent asset look
where's your charger hole fill that up
with how much now you need a little more
water than more
than that but then we can fill it up
yeah it was super cool yeah it was neat
seeing old people there people I didn't
even know about but I talked to Mike
binder for a while and did he was funny
III mean mind of a married man if you
don't recall that joke that was like Sex
in the City for men and that was like
one of the original like sexy in this
issue right but that was he in that he
wrote it they wrote it was him and email
I can
dude he did so he just decides on
[ __ ] thing and like I remember
watching that show and like that was
like late 8th he sounds like original
HBO like sitcom thing and I'm like so
I'm sitting there talking to him I'm
like wow this is [ __ ] surreal as [ __ ]
you know as you would talk to a lot of
these people you know it was fun man
yeah Jimmy Walker was that for me I
talked for a long time pretty legitimate
he was very he was humble we watched him
work who's very humble oh my hey no you
don't want a picture with me I'm like no
I'm really actually dude with like I
really do yeah like a bar is a sitcom
star no he was the one he was like
lights out money back then yeah I mean
he was cool before yeah he was Oh Drake
have stories that was like dynomite he
would just say that and just [ __ ]
that's like let's get ready to rumble
yeah before Kramer absolutely yeah yeah
there he was like black Kramer yeah
because it's like blamer
yeah you had you wrote those sitcoms for
those people the stars and you never has
writers like as writers yeah you just
hope that the other ones are funny too
but then like to have Jimmy walk like
the younger brother take off just
[ __ ] pop yeah dumb [ __ ] what are
you gonna cross a manga for what you
talked about what you talking about
Willis yeah yeah and everyone I give the
black guys listen to me huh you're gonna
say what you talking about Willis all
the time what are you talking about
Willis no no what you talking bout
Willis okay I'll try again in what are
you talking about Willis
back it up okay okay okay yeah no oh
what'd you what'd you talk about Willis
and now I'm exactly dad no matter just
walking home and just say dynomite and
make the milk you have your hands yeah
Mick Jagger t-rex hands and now we're
all getting paid could somebody tell
Rachel to bring my hoodie
itec I called it as you did I got a
texture I'll do it right now
was she over there yeah [ __ ] warriors
pull Game one yeah game what is Game one
I know but like that well we were
talking about home center it is a tone
saturn road and you absolutely I'm
saying okay I'm saying you wouldn't game
one at home when it's new it's like
alright they show them who's game at
home and that's a [ __ ] big deal you
just lost home-field advantage
yeah man is going in it is a big deal
and so now all the pressures on them
they cannot lose this game because the
idea of taking two and in in George and
Google say it seems daunting if you take
one there then just like we gotta want
three seem daunting
it does seem daunting yeah yeah agreed
but if I win this then it's anybody
serious but we were saying this earlier
before you guys got here when we started
this podcast about fifty minutes ago
Erin said that we can go to a four
because there's definitely nobody on
after us that's why I said to me earlier
there's 100% nobody going on after us
remember when because it same thing at
both Cleveland milling man [ __ ]
Boston just blood thought Cleveland
beaten by 22 remember like the first
when the playoffs first started
Cleveland lost their first playoff game
by like 31 yeah and they haven't lost a
playoff game sand all the difference
you're right no but but yes - does not
have a LeBron James who's literally sat
there after the press conference usually
watch the LeBron James uses not have a
LeBron James you don't think no does not
have LeBron James nobody nobody does
nobody James sat there after the Houston
hair after game want the press stars it
goes I'm not worried about this it takes
me in one game if you follow my career
game one I've try to feel out the other
people I'll make adjustments and now
what what that's why they play game too
huh yeah we just got to split this and
there's nobody James Harden of course
hat he has the ability to ball but I
don't think it's in him right now and by
the way by the way Cleveland lost game
on the road I want you to finish that
Chris Paul you're saying they don't I'm
not arguing with you I'm gonna say I'm
trying to understand you're saying those
two don't have that like a legacy of
being able to do that in playoffs or
like they're no well James Harden
they're both well no but they don't have
this thing of like I know how to milk
the playoffs
okay understand I can't buy him that
yeah I know because it both of them are
capable of taking a game oh of course
this as far as Chris Paul's ever been I
understand it so it's like oh [ __ ] how
do you I didn't think about that that's
a good point there's no taking the game
over and then there's not one and then
Woods you're when you're not playing the
game the ability to go I know I'll be
able to take the game over I don't know
if James Harper them have that that's
true yeah that's yet to be well maybe
they could but we haven't seen that is
what you say I can do what I need to do
uh-huh you know that's true I mean I
think do you think all that stuff people
said about LeBron about choked time
whatever that ended a long time ago he's
been I know eight straight final that
was something Jordan had to go to play
baseball for two years to get to six in
a row but they weren't in a row yeah
I'm Jordan is timeline mine is playing
Little League baseball for two [ __ ]
years buying a bus for everyone
cuz the real bus that minor leaguers had
to sit on wasn't comfortable enough for
you to play cards in well he's six foot
six all of them are but and I'm not
making argument Jordan still is a go to
me I'm not yeah but I'm not [ __ ] but
I'm saying eight straight right so I'm
saying I'm saying that reputation has
long since been disproven
so it's like now he's been mostly in his
career the guy who's just [ __ ] sue
people like I know Sam likes to say he's
on HGH by the way punch-drunk doesn't
say that Sam huh nice ass but he's
everything boss should have been all the
records of him being on HGH and multiple
other illicitly think about it well
cocaine and meth
enemy yeah of course and he sells pot to
kids but think about their lucidly to
children about this so eight straight
finals yeah so that is a hundred and
fifteen games a year you include
playoffs one everything right for eight
straight years plus three for two
Olympic runs in those eight years
because the Olympics are every [ __ ]
four years this guy's playing a hundred
fifty basketball games hundred seven
hundred eight let's say that one hundred
seven hundred eight yes yeah yeah you
know depending on seven games four-game
sweep sweep whatever the [ __ ] but in an
two Olympics as well yeah we'll never
skips those David all the time you see a
blow ponder he's going balls
no wonder he's tired I need Shh - but he
doesn't yeah yeah yeah most of it he
does go just go by people
you're on with him and then he just
turns it on he's [ __ ] at that at the
hall yeah his first move is so quick
he's past your hip and then what are you
gonna do just sit on his back and for
somebody that's not making that strong
he's good at getting low yeah so you can
get kind of like under you and then has
this explosive thing I mean eight loss
oxy lost game one on the road when
you're supposed to lose so all he really
if he takes the second game it's [ __ ]
disgrace blitt yeah and by the way if
you lose both bizzy's like still no big
deal I'll take two at home like we're
supposed to well they lose by thirty
again though maybe ya worry if they get
blown yet yeah if they get blown out
again they lose by 22 got on game too is
that effect now I'm like it affects your
mentality yeah yeah because like how Ari
has a phone from the 70s and a camera
from the [ __ ] in 2070 is the this is two
three to these series right - I don't
know three - yeah yeah right one one one
yeah what you want - before I thought to
do is just the finals there's only one
round did it different than everyone
else around a bit yeah I don't know why
they switched just four though oh can we
please also I know we're having a
barbecue for for her later but just for
the present let's all everybody's [ __ ]
on the fight mommy because she was gonna
be here today and I go let's make sure
Aaron we you have a fifth Mike because
I'm gonna
to the fight mommy for showing up here
like she said she would and and now
Aaron doesn't have a mic because of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey yeah let's do that
here you go fight nanny oh you're a
parent now apparently you can't show up
to your job that you don't get paid for
you're dead you got it yes how funny was
hoping did you want you botch holds me
oh god it was gross [ __ ] him and laughed
that hard no likes my face I was I was
in the back well standing next to you
Seth you Stefan bro and Nick Youssef and
I are hugging each other laughing my
mouth so hard when he was he did pretty
much dates out the gates Yeah right he
was just listing all of his stupid gigs
that he had now can paint a Bitcoin one
of his getting he did ten minutes of
dates of where he's gonna be beating him
off of a thing horn shoot in a great
meet to things like where the me to
movements a little looser or there was
me too so I mean I texted Youssef the
next morning I go my face still hurts
from Holtzman no I like 11:00 a.m. I
texted Youssef my face still hurt
Holtzman is time the mustache though is
what's the back hello Hart it said Mitzi
on a child make it just like my kids
would make it for me and I'd have to
wear it yeah was straight out of a van
from the 70s that's like hey kids you
want some candy
ha ha ha are there any pictures from of
him from that we could pull up I don't
know Oh probably um no I got that where
would be where would one be yeah I
imagine I would that one I mean my
[ __ ] face hurts so much
Oh from him and he was like second
you know I know I know Eleanor Eleanor
and then
Hockman and from that it's just like
what are you gonna do oh look at that
mustache I love that you guys want to
dice master for company advice ah [ __ ]
that was really really funny what a fun
night what am I mean I know a lot of
people in but a lot of you know you get
a lot of like comedy nerds that listen
to podcasts and all that sort of stuff
I think and everybody's known us forever
yeah so they know how important this was
it was awesome yeah you know I thought
was interesting as was listened to
everybody in the original room in
[ __ ] 90s and today hits of the 90s
and today yeah thousands and today it
was like every time somebody's talking
about it I would just tarnish that
picture of her you know I could imagine
there ya know young and happy yeah or
just but just there in general even I
try to imagine luck with that wispier
hair up it like mm-hmm
aims like man you could really hear her
do this if I could see her do something
like this yeah and they're just thinking
about her watch and all this if she was
where was the picture just right on
stage next airing yeah just like if she
knew people were saying about it she'd
be like yeah it was like ah no do you
know where they're putting the neon I
did know where I don't know it's always
trying to put in Smithsonian did it put
it in his head room let's put it in a
Tesla and send it to [ __ ] Mars bra
did to my mom did what she went
everybody doing hate when he came out
after Argos and an artist never
mentioned that they were together which
is very famous all he said was very
famous a lot of people yeah and then
Paul II came out and paulie's first
words were like on Mother's Day did he
used to affect my mom right Mother's Day
that's the first thing he said at
Mitzi's [ __ ] thing how apropos how
late did they go
well are you who said you were there
till 3:00 I left it I had a situation so
I left her like 12 or 13 I left at
midnight yeah right about an hour into a
boner pill that I had to pay off
yeah yeah I have to rough I was a
journalist did you really yeah from
drinking eating drinking I didn't eat I
didn't have a single thing I was talking
it was like one of those weddings like I
was talking so much that I just never
went over he was liable even drinking
I was always had a drink in my hand yeah
just you know like where did you throw
up my front yard
oh when you got home yeah I thought you
met at the club no no oh okay no one got
home oh so you drank all night and then
got home yes dad has got to go in the
yard and throw up when you got home or
did you go in the house to realize yo
you would god I knew going we got to
drop magical off he's a windy road then
we drop burn off then I got dropped off
and the guy's car would you we just yeah
we were to get older yeah I was like
yeah once I knew once we dropped off
magic I was like I'm definitely throw
huh it's like I just hope it's not in
his car and then I'm eternal crack in
the window and then I'm dry and then we
got home and I was like I got out I felt
hot I had my suit on yeah all of us
however suited up here and then I was
just like I might as well do it out here
right now writing like it's not sure you
have a good throw up yard though my
in-laws are in town wait so my father
and I woke up in the months I'm gonna
prove in five hours you have a good
throw up yeah yeah yeah
then I came out then I went inside and
threw up later on in the night in the
house and then the kids were like what
happened we heard daddy throwing up no
way yeah and then Tracy's like he had
too much alcohol that said she said it
was like you know what's so [ __ ] up
because we got she got [ __ ] up she
said were supposed to the boys and she
she got [ __ ] up our first night in
real quick sorry sorry sorry do you have
a fire extinguisher
because yeah two of them you got a
situation on the tree house situation oh
all my all large said he's one of the
situation in the tree house is there a
fire so where would that be
yeah it's in the house Thanks tell him
to cut the wall open and get oh there
there well beyond that yeah but Mia my
wife got [ __ ] up on vacation and then
I told the kid she was throwing up and I
was like oh she drank the water remember
don't drink the water and I covered for
her oh yeah for me wait wait
Tracey's smashed she smashed
drunk coming up yeah and they're like
guys this is why we don't find water I
figured I'd use it as adolescent that
such an imprint into your boys mind of
like I will never for the rest of my
days max cream every Mexican I see I
know they drink puke water
yeah no mom just drinks tequila that's
it and that that's so I covered for her
but she I was like [ __ ] you she didn't
cover for me but yeah my father-in-law
will go Beasley I heard you throwing up
outside the right outside his room oh
really yeah see that he's like what a
funny vision what a man to throw up
outside his own home that's what he said
on the front yard you're like [ __ ] I
know how about you gonna sleep in a puke
ass I'll sleep in the tree house not
there anymore by the way Thank You Lars
well it seems like it's like we're just
getting models okay all right yeah yeah
yeah your moneymakers for Steve Steve
Corp oh that's actually a good question
well before we get to that which I do
because I do have a cup of you that I'd
like to run by you but um guys did you
watch UFC I watched a lot of it on a
[ __ ] plane the prelims what Oh my
buddy my buddy hits me out from red zone
and those guys are humongous the biggest
gamblers that I know are the other two
guys at red zone that have the same job
as I I share the same job with two
people
we're basically Andrews Siciliano z'
[ __ ] those two gamble so much that
it's insane they're thrown [ __ ] on
second half's because you know we can
call the we can call the press box of
any stadium and be like hey its own so
from red zone what's up and we can be
the first to be like you know
questionable probable doubtful and
report that they're getting that Intel
and then going money on the second half
and taking unders on the second half
because we know people are out before
Vegas knows are out so they're going
like throwing 500 on under to cover a
$200 bet that is already lost you know
mm-hmm
so here's what you do go to bet DSi comm
use the code punch 25 and what does that
get you 25 free bucks
$25 about with okay whatever you want so
my point is
one of those guys hits me up he knows I
know a lot about the UFC and he goes I
don't know [ __ ] about but I'm putting
money on this card last weekend what do
you know
I picked five fights yeah I didn't bet I
didn't bet on it because I wasn't gonna
watch it I don't like to bet on [ __ ] I'm
not watching mm-hmm I don't because I'm
not that deep but oh yeah if I would
have I should have would you what you
want you got everything I got all five
right and I picked all five hurt all
five right of the main card and but I
changed it and I go actually I'm gonna
go change that I'm gonna go Machida well
I'm gonna go man cheetah other than that
I'm sticking to him sticking to my guns
they're all five I got right Wow and he
hit me up he goes you picked every fight
right off of the main card I go how much
money do when he goes I [ __ ] didn't
[ __ ] bat bullsh
why'd you hit me up then he should have
went to bed DSi DICOM should have used a
good punch 25 he could have thrown all
of what I picked on that card he did a
25-dollar free bet he says and he could
have hit the entire parlay did he just
want to give you money
mmm could be this black bastard remember
uh one of my favorite things that Jim
Carrey who by the way was there the
other night
and I was I was talking to Jim Carrey
for about ten minutes
yeah he's a good dude really good guy
and he looks way better without the
beard but really good guy so he's
sitting and he's sitting on the stairs
at a ballet we're going up to the belly
room and I'm like there was a time where
I'm like I've been talking to Jim Carrey
for seven straight minutes you know I
mean like that actually went through my
head and then I'm like and I did a thing
which is that viagra on it yeah he's on
it it's viagra and he's on it so and
then I was like I did a thing which I
took photos with both of you where
everybody everyone's taking photos with
famous famous people and [ __ ] and I was
like I want to do a like a collage of
everybody that I've met or I started
with here or I've grown up and got
gotten to know in it so I've like
probably 45 photos from you guys -
Vargas Mason - all of us of just the
exact exact same selfie boom and I'm
sitting there Boone everybody and I was
like
any guys just for austerity sake guy
maybe I can get a photo with Jim Carrey
right now that kind of thought went to
my head while were just having an
organic conversation mm-hmm and it
didn't dawn on me that everybody in the
goddamn world wants to take a photo with
him everywhere he ever goes ever
anywhere ever um and that thought popped
in my head and I kind of pulled my phone
out and I was kind of like look you know
he was looking at his phone so I'm like
oh maybe I'll no text and maybe I'll
take a photo and then got my camera set
up put it on the selfie if I can flipped
it kind of thing and then somebody comes
up and like hey Jim you mind if I take a
quick photo with you and he goes ah
we're not doing that today I just don't
ever like thank God thank you idiot we
like all this guy I'm [ __ ] ruining
the moment
yeah yeah yeah I mean photo come on yeah
what an [ __ ] right who would do that
right James videotape right James so
anyways guys memorial you go to bed to
his side and use the code punch 25 they
get you 25 free bucks to bet with and
cut on anything man bet on anything
I said I'll cash there it's fun to lay
it down it's fun to lay it down I I've
calculated sights by the way um I didn't
watch them because I watch him either
but uh but I did catch up and it was a
record for the most amount of finishes
in a UFC event really and that includes
from the fight pass to the prelims to
the main event in that whole three card
run because you know they split it up
and like that most amount of finishes
and that's the Ezekiel choke no oh so
[ __ ] cool who pulled that off some
dude was getting his ass beat and then
got out with that in this Ezekiel where
you're underneath yeah I'm in love I
don't know we're in the bottom I don't
even know how work choke sit in the
bottom are extremely rare
other than triangles I'm talking about
like hand chokes from the bottom well
when Nate Diaz got that [ __ ] triangle
from the bottom and then that was fasted
in
it plenty of time he's like it's done I
hope I hope this thing comes to fruition
of Nate Diaz and GSP why not why not
at 55 I don't see GSP maker I was told
by the way GSP and GSP was at MIT
ceasing I talked to him fro but and he
guaranteed that he was gonna call in
today and so did Nate and Nick Diaz and
all cuz I might say guess who else is it
said he was gonna call in talk to you
about rifling through yes I'm very mad
about you rifling he was going on a
tirade about you rifling through his
affairs admits he's singing like dice we
get it I know he did it he's a nothing
oh he was very upset is that the fight
right there yeah I'm gonna
can you pull that up we have cameras
over there
and they're also I don't know that's a
great question if you ask werein he's
gonna get [ __ ] mad at you did Aaron's
gonna kill you all right Aaron okay set
up because this set up that's that's
where it starts I'm sorry yeah that's
what so anyways so when I left the party
about two hours later I got myself into
this situation and that's just you know
but [ __ ] asking kicked I mean the
guys bleeding like craziness guys like
what happened he got up standing up he
could get it tear this out Larry but
didn't matter it's like the look on his
face or his exile from so yeah such a
dominant position did this to you Larry
did you do this to you you were better
than this we're better than this kind of
okay here you go it's gonna be oh yeah
okay so that's where it starts okay see
that there
this video start with an apology for not
getting the right video the first time
or is it okay it's just so it's on
Oh see he he'd set it up there oh and he
pulled him down to it
yeah but he's even a half guard he's not
even like didn't even have full guard on
him he only has happen or it's half
guard yeah you almost won half guard at
night I guess yeah in that show guard
please but watch his face right he is a
god damn it Carl
you [ __ ] Carl you [ __ ] me and you
[ __ ] me again I'm not she's gonna have
that baby yep
she's gonna have that she agreed for the
abortion for the win who didn't who
didn't so what that's a pretty that's
arguably the best bet DSi see what do
you think what the Yankees so far
haven't talked about it yet this is what
a year it's amazing for players with are
you guys overconfident uh what no
they're too young to be over it's going
on we're talking about the u k-- the fan
no Stanley Sanchez aren't even hitting
it no and we'll come down to earth and
we'll be but the fact that the team
could hang with all the we're not what
you reckon right now twenty eight and
twelve the best record in Major League
Baseball by over seven hundred but the
team's 17-under to even the top don't
like 21 and that nineteen game streak
the teams that we dismantled were angel
we had a for Houston Boston
yeah we beat Boston so like you're
talking top-level wonder the a is but
we're hitting meaningful home runs we're
catching up on teams it's I mean showing
it's never over how does it as a Cubs
fan as you're pitching because they've
asked vo Epstein how does it feel to
watch this and our kids up and down I
mean you've got a world series out of it
yeah because he was Chapman and we got
Andujar back yeah and really that Cubs
won the World Series weari signed
Chapman and we got this kid now who's
just like a utility I love him he's all
over the lights he's go go go he can hit
he's not he'll hit a home run but he'll
[ __ ] throw one into the gap and he
just runs and I like that yeah they're
all there you know they're it's not even
their team's of like or all to 29th
where they're young they grew up
together in the farm they played
together for a while so and I don't know
how he how he's doing as a coach but it
seems to be jailing so far I'm Sanchez
it's not gonna be they're not gonna play
700 ball how many games you've been to
it
engineer I was one Yankees at Angel
Stadium oh you did yeah when Gregorius
hit the home run and then they all went
nuts they gave him a they gave him a
curtain call at Angel Stadium
Wow that's what at Angel Stadium
really curtain call he came out and did
it Oh for shame or shame for shame that
proves my point kids everything that
proves my point
what that CSI deals on it mm-hmm no no
that that's a garbage team yeah angels
or no garbage their Disney team yeah
they're not they claim to be LA but
they're like an hour and a half away
from [ __ ] LA you're in you're in like
earth line you might as well be like
vine improv angels Aaron your thoughts
on the Angels he loves him he was a
thumbs-up big thumbs up so hey hey the
Angels got the pools at exact worst year
yeah one of the best trades 490 million
dollars
he was so overpriced and they were like
we got the last good year out of them
you take and immediately he was far
worse yeah yeah yeah that's like yeah
likes like Shammi shows and like 91 or
whatever you're like hey Wow
I mean look you know what I like the way
this guy's slowly turning white and his
home runs are going down let's get my
gazillion dollars the Otani kids still
doing really well though he has his
hitting home runs home runs and pitching
a great game every five days his both
dads he did a pitch last night or the
night before I think he had you know you
got a we got a lit up once and it's like
three or four the really good games but
he I think he's got like six home runs
okay on the offensive side yeah we were
close weren't we well he didn't want to
go to need it he he want to go to a West
Coast team I heard oh so he could play
both ways yeah oh no I think what Chris
it's closer to Japan I remember when
maybe 3 and 1 on the season
3.58 URI but it was three good games in
one bad but but remember like when it
was like how many home runs team 16 and
a half during the [ __ ] spring when it
was like this guy five homers I in 20
games
69 a bath Ferb yeah a pitch
we're talking about you know yeah he's
already ate those Cody 348 REE 43 runs
yeah but he's not he's not getting
at-bats when he's pitching he's getting
up now yeah I know it but when they play
and by the way yeah in early games like
you know fun we're gonna we're gonna
guide you to do that yeah exactly
as a guys like I get to pitch you know
you're not putting somebody on or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah I get to just
[ __ ] swing a bat [ __ ] six times a
pph whatever yeah a couple times of one
why not that's like well it'll help the
team yeah changeless yeah Deion Sanders
yeah he was like a he was like fine but
he wasn't like a we're gonna [ __ ] win
because you're on the team when you play
baseball did one of my favorite Deion
Sanders moments was all of them by the
way because I loved that guy so much it
was the best but when he wasn't the same
thing but he when he took a helicopter
when he's playing in Miami from [ __ ]
Monday Night Football to [ __ ] play
bass yeah listen I was dope his [ __ ]
yeah the Braves that's when he was with
the place but there was one where he's
like so fast and it's like he's on first
and somebody gets like a Brian Jordan or
somebody like that got Dave Justice
somebody gets a single and he's on first
and he [ __ ] around second and now
he's rounding third he's coming around
so fast and then there's a play at the
plate and DN pretty much just jumps
right in this dude and [ __ ] lays the
catcher out ladies a catcher out catcher
drops a ball and Deion [ __ ] slams his
hand on home plate and the announcer
goes welcome to the NFL I mean he creams
the catcher like it was like a receiver
coming across the middle ha ha she
screams him welcome to the NFL it was
the best oh I love Deion I had a hat for
every baseball team Dion played for I
saw Dion play with the Reds
I saw play with San Francisco I saw him
play with Atlanta I saw him play really
was in the San Francisco I went to a
Dodgers game
just cuz Dion was playing and Wars ham
Cisco had I don't I only bought that hat
just for primetime
I loved tea on Sanders I was a grown
[ __ ] man he was at Ball State
University I was in my early 20s when
that [ __ ] left the Falcons and
went to the [ __ ] Niners for what it
was waited to me a million dollars he
was a found 1 million dollars more and
he just built the Georgia Dome which you
described that's what deep the house
Edina and by the way and by the way he
also has just he was just becoming the
game-changer that he was yeah he was the
John yeah he was that's yeah he would
become him yeah you're like my man yeah
it wasn't you get the middle for a few
rights at its best it was like you write
as best as that's going right and in
Dallas after that and then I cried as a
goddamn grown adult I was 23 years old I
cried at Ball State University when this
guy [ __ ] left the Falcons and I had a
oh and by the way that reminds me it
does it I think the fires gotten out of
hand I had a I had a we had a kiddy pool
in my living room at Ball State
University that we used to just like
just sit in the pool there may not be
watching the game but I'm sitting in the
pool so we had like one of those like
kiddie pools in there and so there was
no water in it fire bro all of my dion
jerseys cut them all up with scissors
lit him on fire and just watch them burn
in that [ __ ] kiddie pool inside your
yeah dorm no no it was apartment what it
was an apartment indoors [ __ ]
melodramatic can't ya know I was like
dude you're out bro hahaha
white jersey black just had a home and
all humming away humming away cut him up
burn them down by Felicia how many Drive
from that show I see more Jersey so I
thought red one know a silver one black
one how many different Jersey yeah how
many Jersey he was a game changer on
this throw to me and the odds of you
scoring are the same as I you know catch
a little bubble screen and it would to
be gone you're like he Dion was one
here's here's a phrase that you use for
greatness he
it again it's LeBron if it's Jordan or
whatever like you're like Tiger Woods
Deon you know he just gets the ball in
it on a bubble screen takes it seven
years like this [ __ ] did it
again sneak one for me
you hope don't you yeah buddy you don't
take one Barkley it's been what well
that's the new Giants running back the
second second pick overall and I think
he really is gonna be something special
I was texting you about it when I was
taking a bath you yeah I was in here
they didn't get the [ __ ] Jew from
UCLA that guy's gonna suck whoo-hoo
rosin rosin yo ro just gonna suck yeah
no I know why why would he base well
you're afraid so because you're know cuz
you had the same zone for one game and
that game was a fluke thing where he's
throwing it through through defenders
hands that he's not that good
he didn't showed the ability atletic Lee
he's intelligent sure you expect that
from above someone if it's a time but
like what do you need UCLA grad no part
of the white test well that's party
buddy gets try they're like oh you must
be smart
obviously it's always Wonderlic scores
yeah I think we knows what he's talking
but no I think Josh Allen's best
quarterback are Devon but I was I agree
with that wholeheartedly I was a lot of
Robert burger drafting none of these
guys getting say qualms Barkley getting
Dez Bryan now he fell to you they get
this bright I know we're going to I
think do you think so look I don't think
you will I can pull holes of football
well oh the pool halls are fun man we
can't no he can't separate a thousand
yards I just need a big red zone target
throw it up to me up in the air and let
me go fight for it he can give you real
but he doesn't do that maybe gives you
no separation he still can do that like
Keyshawn and like over a year his point
of the ball we had it with Brandi
Marshall and it didn't work out his way
he was wasn't as hell that was and I
think that's why you guys won't cuz I
don't think you guys want to have to
Brandon Marshalls in a row I don't think
he don't have to pay me right that who's
not the lady Ross well of course he
would do it for free - who's you - well
we'd say Odell Beckham yep and you got
Victor Cruz over like those kind of slot
receivers oh you got a chance
have the new kid Shepherd and the the
Ingram need the the tight-end but I'm
saying that no one like throw it up and
go get it 6 foot 5 dez bryant good out
he doesn't matter you'll sell tickets
the Giants are nine years away from
proposing a winning route season so I
think so it's fine if they want to get
him just like sell some tickets
I think Berkeley I think the our coaches
change that franchise I really do
Jason Witten said today he thinks Dez
Bryant's gonna go the Packers by the way
another thing I wouldn't hey if you
could if you're Dez Bryant who I want
throwing the ball to me the best
quarterback in the world yeah I'll go to
play for the panty man right no come on
not the what not the highest-paid he's
best so many receivers look great think
about all the shitty received really
great white receivers look great exactly
hey good riddance to him we don't need
them
good yeah I'm not feeling bad at all
about that Jason wish it I'm like that
hurts our team that does hurt just Brian
I'd say without her I tell you about her
because of the timing of it because you
retired after the draft yeah kind of as
a surprise had you told us I was an
organization he was planning I think he
really was just the idea crew in his
head more and more that's fine but had
you told us as an organization maybe in
February I'm leaning towards retirement
our draft board would have looked very
different huh cuz now we just I mean you
were a staple in our everything you had
nobody else weren't even thinking about
it no you didn't mean and now you're now
you want to draft a Titan but you can
get what are the odds that he says no
[ __ ] I'm gonna play yeah zero and if
not this year next year zero well here's
the deal don't want to talk him into
it's Jerry Jones so Jerry Jones will
assess what he has now he'll go out or
try to find someone and if not come July
he's gonna start chirping huh buck and
uh huh okay how about this how about
that but there's a lot of good like
free-agent hard there tight ends out
there is JC Wayne I just started eating
right if I was a Cowboys you know who
have a sign it's only Oh gates
how about this this is the same goddamn
guy how about gates same goddamn guy how
about their 82 or nine and three and
they say Jason you got another week or
two to get ready come play come play
just for the last run of it we're for
sure gonna make the playoffs we're gonna
make a run to the Super Bowl well you
guys I know but if it come help us win
one well we still don't have a wrestle
to the tight end I hear you got to take
off seven games I wouldn't listen would
not say I'd argue doing all right here
from nine and two without me but you
know whatever
and let's not forget to you know I think
he's the Fox or whoever he just signed
with yeah it's they were learning fo
like a million bucks they would love
that they would let him out of course
they would but like would you want to
Jay Cutler was gonna do it laughing Fox
announcer and then but it's like your
job safety we'll come back next year
we'll hire you go do this would be
[ __ ] Brad if our announcer it's the
[ __ ] guy there let's say they had a
tight in the filter they did pretty well
and then he got injured and they're
getting thing we need sure I'd do it
yeah I would yeah over and over again
well but you're also not going to sign
and play our shitty season with the
bills exactly know at 39 or 38 these
guys everyone back to my same guys and I
always wanted a ring with this you know
and he I would do it to go back to the
same squad last season was I wouldn't be
a gun for hire no no no no I would do
yeah of course they would and that's
that would be neat yeah I think that
would be neat yeah way they do it tight
end now I don't know probably I mean I
mean Witten releases like classic kind
of like of course you would say that but
look listed all three tight ends that
are basically in the film room they're
like that mark Jason Witten he's like
you know Moe Larry and curly if these
guys don't be great without means like
of course you're gonna say now one of
these guys that's a PC thing to say give
them to me
Blake jar one no idea Oh Blanca
Jeff Jeff Swain good white Rico gathers
Rico gathers is probably the best of the
three is he listed as three seconds yeah
Niko gathers well I think be the tight
end of the cow Dalton Schultz and then a
guy called David Wells not the pitcher
says Dave Hills not the pitcher David
Wells I mean honestly you got to be big
so maybe triple he could do it could
oh I meant to bring this letter I got a
there was a tinfoil hat letter at the
Comedy Store I took it I was gonna open
I I just thought about Aaron Rodgers
with they just they signed
what's-his-name to the tight end the
packers uh that it's no the one from
Bennet know the big redhead from used to
be on Seattle then he went to cram Jimmy
Graham Oh Jimmy Graham that's right
Jimmy Graham and Dez Bryan getting to
throw up that's a lot of height man yeah
that is a lot of reso to get to the 20
Bryant's like Keshawn now though in his
late career what's he's like I'll make a
few captures he's a serviceable guy
that's about it I mean he's gonna give
you what he's been giving you yeah which
is six hundred yards and three
touchdowns
that's not 12 million dollar money no
even the NFL million dollars but that's
why he's on the hook for yeah that's why
he's unemployed he'll get a million to
play somewhere those guys not you know
what a million dollars is in the NFL as
a wide receiver 700 yards and four
touchdowns yeah million dollars would
you watch if you could get him in his
prime but in his butt right now
but he'll be in his prime you know yeah
from the past to the Giants would you
watch him have sex with your wife
oh I would totally watch him [ __ ]
spray-down you were oh you oh yeah that
was talkin bout your wife but I guess
that course was for you because I wanted
without that you would you'd be into it
no but if he's thrown up in the yard on
the outside he's throwing up in the yard
and just in the window is wearing a
condom in the window it's just yeah I
still the press oh just you know it's
not about this I'm not racist again
water cuz you drink Mexican water I'm
gonna say it's a hard no or a hard no
yup like hard job you know or like yeah
hand job no no hand you know no no no
what if you could give a hand job okay
too desperate to get this brightness it
is prime but you have to give the hand
job to this Brian make your mouth that
is the magic that is the magic but
you've got to give them a hand job with
your mouth so it can be reversed genie
in a bottle I'm trying to get this the
line of NFL players out there trying to
get the genie out of the bottle and into
your mouth no mouth no mouth but you do
have to jerk it off on to you leg
stomach yeah
yeah that's the weird calm on your part
but for maybe like four inches into your
[ __ ] it's somewhere on your on you
though on you anywhere it can be really
like right on your leg or it could be
like in your mouth and whatever you want
it I'm gonna say hard yes you never know
what's gonna blow like house like would
it be great if that was Tracy Tracy a
hard no Tracy a hard no me yeah hard yes
yeah what dedicated fan yeah I would
love that if he just stared I will
tomorrow indication as to when the
climax is coming surprises both
surprises easily you too sir even after
the procedures little Bryce smile
[Laughter]
there's a very funny video of that
little Jack in a box I guess that's you
know jack-in-the-box thing in it but
it's like kids seeing it for the first
time ever and they're all terrified and
it scares the living [ __ ] out of it's
all three-year-olds or whatever the [ __ ]
but it's just like but it's the parents
are you know turn the crank are the kids
to turn the crank but they have no clue
that it's coming it's know so they don't
have that trepidatious fear of like
they're just like I don't know what the
[ __ ] what oh here it is right here some
of them think it's funny and it's really
a funny video for like human nature
because some of them think is they laugh
and they're like that was awesome and
volume you like that was awesome and
then there's times where like see these
kids like that was great kids a [ __ ]
what a dumb [ __ ] but there are some kids
that look at their parents like oh why
would you do this to me
this kid's gonna freak the [ __ ] out he's
the boy oh boy it's not gonna like it
oh we did the volumes off huh yeah I
know I think it's just coming through
this oh yeah because of the modulation
he's ahead of this oh boy why kids
dumbest [ __ ] this guy if that kids not a
heroin addict right now I did he's like
Jesus lady what the [ __ ] he's already
scared he was already scared just that
music was coming out yeah the volumes
off from this device that a clown dude
that popped out he was scared that the
music was coming
terrifying yeah dude nobody wants to no
one's ever seen a clown like I love this
man no this kids just gonna fall in
shopping cart it's just kids getting
hurt like bad at all I would love it is
like but it's so funny when the kids
like why would you do this to me a doll
time to put all my trust in you look at
his dumb [ __ ] kid that looks like an
old school one - that thing's all rusty
and [ __ ] like that Instagram there's
just an Instagram kill drinking hurt all
right this is not a kid that's like it
yeah this guy's a bully's never seen
this before
yeah I don't like it when they're happy
yeah I hate when the kids do like it oh
here we have this little Asian kids
about to get what's coming to him I mean
it held it right in his face
[ __ ] that kid [ __ ] tech person who did
this video
it was awful yeah do they have the sound
off you just you can hear it no I had I
mean awesome we could hear but it was
off from there to here
how to put this can you let's do an
impression you have a good of Johnny
impression oh yeah yeah lately it sounds
exactly like him Johnny wait Johnny
yes yes oh sorry I thought it was Johnny
talking into no no doing the impression
she put your alarm
what's your alarm code what the crib yes
I don't mind how to tell you over the
air but well it rhymes with probably
should you probably should I got trust I
actually was like oh I'll give him my
phone did I don't know how to break the
CRE there's no real Lars I don't know I
don't know he's like 108 and looking at
my phone oh yeah we still got 10 uh so
he dates I'll be the DC improv oh nice
first second third nice maybe and we
will be at skank fest and for any of
your skank fest info go to Ari Shaffir
down glass or skank fest yeah and that's
probably the best place to get any small
their gear - right yep yeah of Shaffir
fresh shorts okay alright how did the
pew beard go you mustache awful okay
paid off the bag of bets now so do we
have the website where it shows the
outstanding bets and stuff it does do
you do what you'd look down away from my
eyes no it does really not trust that
it's not the paws are all of our bets
yeah are all the bets on the website
right now yeah those no no it doesn't
seem like you really are I think that's
just our all of our bets on the website
yes that does it I don't down in a way
how you said yeah up and left is lying
everybody knows so what the [ __ ] was it
what's down and right rihanna is
thinking that's contemplative that's
because you were under template if is
that true up in a lot up and left is
this is still on the test you i don't
want people i said it's up no mommy was
drinking open water
that's what's wrong that's what had
happened well you said was gonna paper
first what was the bet that you had lost
the loser for testing he could name ten
baseball teams we keep it easy and we
let him do it
so then who's she was only his pubes no
Jason
and what's the codes also but he forgot
to tell them to let them grow out so
they've had very few no like shave off
so it was mostly his pubes and that's
why because I noticed that it was just
only a Hitler man water station all
right off Sam had puberty you for him
wink ins I'm had like a big-ass beard of
years and I already see it getting him
what was the smell like that's that was
wrong it was bad that's so great do you
say the smell was wrong yeah that's a
that's the adjective the I'm used to
describe mallet after was off your mouth
when it was on there I could smell it at
first because I want getting my nose
smell and then when I find like just
breathe regular and like you know how
you breathe a little bit of yeah so what
I was a good it was Erica it was like
rotten no no no the spirit come you
could when that was on there I could
smell the spirit gum yeah yeah and then
they just glued a bunch of pubes to your
there we go Stevie look there
now that that kind of looks like almost
like a [ __ ] like a it looks like the
operation thing yeah Tim palm pins on
there to unware oh she's got pubes in
there well her pubes are in there no but
her juices are on louis's pubes for sure
that's not too shabby oh so gross
I mean that's the best thing you can add
you go about 35 minutes with that on
there do you miss it it was like a warm
blanket dude I couldn't breathe in
through my nose at all so tonight is
talking to your biases yeah I was like
Casey Kasem oh yeah I would I would
write to your mouth everything right now
oh you tasted it then no I kept it off
like a bull act on it but then the
problem is my nose started running
because it wasn't right through dripped
on like the outer of my butt like the
outer part of it ah that reminds me of
it it was ripping so it's like
reactivating the old piss and stuff oh
that reminds me of a story where my
friend was and I think you and I were
talking about this earlier that my
friend used to like in the winter there
was like this sandbox but it would
freeze over because it's winter so it's
like a playground sandbox but all these
cats in the neighborhood used to [ __ ]
sandbox box like it was a big cat thing
little girl we used to take this little
girl to eat these little cat turds like
who's like I was frozen Snickers bar and
you could just hear crack off oh she
would and then she would just suck it
like a lollipop til it would like thaw
out and then it's like you just sucking
on a turd now with your head but nobody
wants that I think what do you mean
nobody wants that in their life nobody
wants to listen to your [ __ ] you [ __ ]
poop I don't even cater litterbot
that's a picture of it this [ __ ] guy
gets a picture of his iPad like me nice
fluffy oh [ __ ] makes my face hurt
well guys that's been another episode
oh wait so that's a let me ask a
question you chef wants to know should
he bring anything besides firearms okay
yeah let me ask you a question about
bagger bats yeah for the us a chance
somewhere public
is that the deal just like a big yep
okay ma'am
either subway or somebody's great we're
just about a park like I never wanted a
park to do it park would be fine a big
place full of people you know you're in
the air and I even I'll even accept a
Yankee game I was thinking of doing it
there that's a great one of God's
thinking a great one get a home run you
know somebody hits a home run get the
USA chant going i got filled I said I
would yeah I was just at my first game
when they [ __ ] march out one of those
[ __ ] veterans to show that they're
not [ __ ] abandoned I'm left and right
they show one like give him a house and
stuff and they all wave I'm gonna
[ __ ] get it going right there yeah
that's an easy way to do that I would
even be willing to accept uh it's
funnier to me like I'll show myself some
non-american crab at home er yeah oh
yeah or they take out her like a Latin
relief pitcher and they bring in a guy
we wanna you and say exactly you good
work
I totally agree with that that yeah
that's totally fine yeah my other
thought was it do it like this to put
people on the subway but put a friend
like way down and then put someone else
like somewhere in the middle her film
but maybe the way down filming somewhere
in the middle and then I'm on the other
side and he's like oh my god
they [ __ ] they killed a sod or
something like that and then me way over
the side go you and look involved uh-huh
and then get someone else to like join
across from the guy with the phone
joining in and then if they can all join
we keep I could get it going yeah just
waiting for some sort of breaking news
of like a political good also like I
could have done but I thinking about
Osama but
that was you know art like eight years
ago yeah yeah it's too late it's been a
hot minute what about like when we won
World War two yeah yeah that's not it's
just a story USA chant oh I got it I got
it back a bit I got a bad batch I
thought about the shower for three days
I already had the [ __ ] exact like
timelines and everything shave a
swastika into your head already are way
ahead of you buddy
shave us again here's the timeline to do
it you have up to three months but you
don't have to do it like right away in
case something big is happening we have
everything it has to be three full days
no hat wearing no hat wear no hot
wearing three full days of a visible
swastika you could pick the three days
ahead of that but three in a row and you
up to three months to pay it all I can't
do that dude I can I just say the irony
of a Jewish man fantasizing about
shaving a swastika into his head while
he's in the shower is amazing is amazing
you would not do that that's the move
right to put deadlines on these don't
you think certain deadlines where it's
like we don't some of them we like you
have to do it starting tonight that's
the ones triple-a always has troubles
with but sometimes you should be like
sometime in the next two weeks or
something the next this it has to be
done no holy draw again what what do you
know the bank
I know exactly or just don't or just
make a figure out of three days we're
like it's Tracy I can't leave the house
I can't pick the kids up and exactly I
can't I can't
yeah you like choose have to be this
summer for me I'd have to do it in my
house in Long Island yeah or we're on
the road or my dad oh it was a style I'm
happy about it yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying you have up to three months when
it's the when it's the end with five
five like I saw Black Hawk whatever at
the end when we said has to be starting
today your next fighters that's like all
right that's part of the joy of it this
is like just it's gonna be hard so get
it done right it's gonna be a difficult
one three months you wouldn't do it I
wouldn't I would do that wait wait three
months baby baby talk yeah I just shave
just watch the game to my head can I
wait your Christmas yeah you're right
now do I have to shave it or like around
the tattoo of the swastika that's
already on my head right maybe one of
the small lighters at least a small
lighter so it's the bit it's gonna be
font like big yeah and it can't be like
with with hair over it's very clear just
to make it very clear but everything
that you're making a swastika yeah I
would do that again and keep hearing you
the same joke just for different for the
size of a small lighter to a big letter
man
yes so that's like you know three inches
square three square inches basically
nothing no yeah the problem is then
after that you have to shave your head
yeah yeah
you said three months you have to
complete it yeah every month on base or
what do you think or join a cult or just
hang what's the right amount of time for
you to get it done in to get it done in
or to to have to keep it I would say
keep it for two years and then you have
to do it immediately the next morning
well if you just have to let it grow out
no that's way worse that's the way worse
it's really like you will you will have
to do what I'm figuring out my day like
I can't go to the gym I can't go to
Orangetheory and go [ __ ] absolute up
in the yard right pushes in yard like a
regular [ __ ] straight up a lot of
white supremacist here's a real risk now
in my neighborhood I'll be alright but
you're gonna get gas you stop at a gas
station
nope Tracy's getting out you choose the
side we're back he's right man you you
pretty much in the witness-protection
robbery to change like what if Tracy's
like I like it
[Laughter]
tuition that would be a real twist in
our relationship oh that's fun yeah yeah
and then you're like oh I kind of like
that you like this next thing you know
you guys are [ __ ] like it's like what
six months be better with four must be
better like what's the right amount of
time for you to block it would suck but
it's not everywhere my life force good
for months because that's yeah visit
that's a third of the year yeah that's a
full season all right guys Aaron's
giving me that
these bets - you know it's coming you
know you know it's coming like like like
like if it's offseason back we're like
you know 30 games out I know where I'm
not gonna be your team yep you know and
then it's just like you might as well
just do it well I'm gonna I'm gonna do
it tomorrow and do do a test run and let
you guys know how it goes and I'll wear
it for a month or you just have to be so
specific or Samuel finds I'm so specific
that [ __ ] cry-baby a swastika in the
head at least the size of a smaller I
put two inches by two inches we gotta
sign off on that one for ya bro I signed
off on it he just did he's on skype
right there must wear for three straight
days with no hat complete within three
or four months ah
alright guys that's been punch rock
Aaron's give me the wrap-it-up sign I
don't know who's coming I don't know
please alright
no one oh yeah are you trying to
impregnate your wife still this is the
exact table relation moment you had
what's coming in comedy film there oh
how you doing Aaron how you been how st.
Louis doing [ __ ] you with that is about
right yeah but you're like grapes are in
first place
mmm it's early everyone that's right
really I mean it comes on like what a
game and a half out at [ __ ] 21 and 16
or something alright
we should be yeah they should [ __ ]
Dodger fan man so in the World Series
you're getting hurt Kershaw's hurt
alright we should all do a bet on who's
the team is gonna be the best in the New
York Yankees I'm down for that your
night with you though maybe what is the
what is the best the best record at the
end of the season were season the
regular size I mean that's the bet that
got a hot dog in your ass [ __ ] sucking
everybody thanks for listening and I'm
sure we're without that suck it there's
no better than all the